We want to do something similar to what McDonald's
does, which will eventually
arrive in coffee shops so that you
no longer need the cashier function and
no longer need it to the extent to
free up the cashier for other
activities, so you have these kiosks
with which you can order
We're piloting it now. At some point you'll have
your app or a QR code on the table with
which you can order
to digitize the checkout process. A
very large project also
has huge economic implications because basically 30% of the
personnel costs come through this
checkout function and we do  In 5
years we probably don't want to
need them anymore because we want to take the few
people we can get
into
production and into
coffee production, for example